up next we'll debate club boys but first
we got our boy Josh this is Josh
Sullivan
hey what up Brendon what up - yo it's
your boy Sullivan from Chattanooga
Tennessee
yep Sully and I think I might have the
Omega level 5 star difficulty debate
club question for you guys alright so
let me know what you think I'm looking
for the ultimate pump up jam hitter dude
and it's really just between two songs I
have a tiger you forget that Rocky 3
rocky 4 rocky 5 Rocky 6 rocky 7 98
hitter dude huh danger zone kenny
loggins son that [ __ ] that guy Tom
Cruise turned to Scientology boy too
many lone bike rides with us in your
headphones dude you don't get believing
in all kinds of guys hello y'all set me
straight gang getting buzz buzz gang
gang great question dude I gotta be
honest that a danger zone does nothing
for me really know that danger on some
bull don't do OK I kind of like it now
[Laughter]
no you're thinking of gonna born to be
wild yeah here's the thing dude you want
a song to pump you up by jock jams
volume to everyone who's a hater on hey
hey sex music right yeah or Mahadevan
Broncos music whatever I'm gonna say man
this is for me this is the easy one when
telling us Hughes so it's obviously that
eye of the tiger there you did that it's
just anything anything can happen that I
haven't I got a lot of children been
conceived of that song oh man my stuff's
been created I had a tiger yeah I had
the tiger who wrote that song semester
storm did he really think so yeah yeah
like if his hair is like kind of died of
interesting it's prime and survivor
yes so who wrote it right there yes I've
shown them write that [ __ ] the years
delay thought that yeah dumbasses oh no
come on what do they got in here what is
it either who wrote it Frankie Sullivan
and drum can we get a picture to look at
Frankie Sullivan seems like you know
Frankie oh yeah I met that guy yeah I
met the guy on the left actually can I
hear it can I hear it one time yeah let
me just let's just refresh the memory
because I'm going hard in the paint on
that danger zone [ __ ] I hear here's
that thing I think Top Gun so overrated
Top Gun yeah
[ __ ] up the show the planes aren't
that fast no dude yeah look at that
oh yeah bro there I am
mmm there I am he got his always falling
in with them yeah came out that's mmm
that's me yeah yeah dude look at these
boys oh the dickwad oh it's a whole
squad how's it gonna have 107,000
dislikes what kind of terrorist dislike
this lorda fans probably I'm gonna go
straight up and say this has got it for
me dude
all day
ah this that Philadelphia [ __ ] this
is kind of [ __ ] you may somebody - did
and then apologized he'll yeah this
where you buy a [ __ ] Geno's Philly
cheesesteak and spike in somebody's face
how many times you think someone just
[ __ ] up walking how these boys did it
then thing this is America [ __ ]
man now that I'm hearing it again broad
dangerzone [ __ ] hit real quick we all
top gun was a gay plot correct buzzing
ah
dude look watch and play [ __ ]
volleyball yeah no pants yeah nope
boys of the summer hair kenny loggins 46
million views how many dislikes only
8,000 hmm lot of game in the same outfit
on Oh get straight to the hard-hitting
[ __ ]
danger zone it's kind of see you run
from the cops too dude poor Robert Enke
this song sweet so bro Rocky
let me hear it I don't know ah
come on it's giving me up more it's give
me up more than either Tiger no way
[ __ ] Russians to that song whoo
I didn't want it to bro and it did how
do you think I feel I've been taking
advantage of bubble music Kenny Loggins
still alive huh yeah yeah he live
forever no I don't think so yeah I think
that Loggins damn near killed him dude
is he alive he's still alive everyone
wrote oh it's like 70 tell me one
was he 19 when he wrote that got eight
children
dude he also sings Footloose I'm sorry
cheerleader I don't like that one
Brendon I don't like going either so I'm
gonna go I'm gonna stick with the eye of
the tiger though that's my hometown Jam
someone rock with that one that
Louisiana state riot I get all [ __ ]
day I don't like Top Gun I like danger
zone what was in a weird 7% I have a
tiger yeah America
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]